so this morning I woke up and when I
checked the news I saw that this NHL
player is being berated by the general
public because there was a pregame Pride
event and because he's Russian Orthodox
Christian and he decided that he didn't
want to participate in it because he's
very religious sounds like he's a bit of
a racist to me so they're calling him a
homophobe and a bigot and hateful and uh
here's a really quick video that I
wanted to share with you and want to get
your thoughts on it let's see it pride
jerseys during warm-ups to celebrate the
lgbtq plus Community however defenseman
Ivan provorov would not join them on the
ice citing his Russian Orthodox beliefs
here's what he said after the game
yeah I uh I respect everybody and I
respect everybody's choices my choice is
to stay true to myself and my religion
that's all I'm gonna say it's gonna walk
away the Flyers issuing this statement
here's how it rates the Philadelphia
Flyers organization is committed to
inclusivity and is proud to support the
lgbtq plus Community many of our players
are active in their support of local
lgbtq plus organizations and we were
proud to host our Annual Pride night
again this year the Flyers will continue
to be strong advocates for inclusivity
and the lgbtq plus Community by the way
prob did in fact play with the squad
after warm-ups they're making it seem
like a like he
tortured lgbtq plus people he just
simply said I don't want to participate
this man was hired to play hockey he was
hired not to Pander to to every
corporate whim that the NHL has and
that's what really I'm finding really
frustrating here that people are then
saying he's a bigot his comments were
extremely respectful I respect
everybody's choices but I don't want to
participate for my own reasons I mean it
and then there were just people railing
on him and literally in the name of
Tolerance I don't get why you have to be
like Pro support lgbtq stuff why do you
have to support means like you literally
support it not like you're just okay
with it like it means you support it
like even the way you word stuff means
something so why why do they shove down
our throats do you support this you must
support it it's like why do I have to
support it do you support straightness
or do you just you just fine with it yes
am I missing am I wrong so no you're
you're right you just leave it alone
just if you don't want if you're not
into something you just leave it alone
he's not doing any harm and he couldn't
have been more respectful but you know
so I put some something up on Twitter
about this today and it's blowing up
with comments anti-religious comments
you know homophobe comments saying that
I support hate because I believe that
this man has a right to his own opinion
and I cannot believe how much hate I'm
getting on my oh you're pulling it up on
my Twitter today he and no one should be
forced to participate in a company
company social political agenda that is
not directly tied to the organization's
main purpose leave him alone
all right so it's on so I put the same
comment on the uh Fox News okay you're
right so it's on the Fox News comment
thread it's getting a lot of traction if
you scroll down a little bit I just put
this up an hour ago and there's a ton of
con conversation going on here
so here are some guys so just wait until
the hate crime is committed so the law
can step in as opposed to educating
others on inclusion and acceptance
because I wrote Because this guy was
like we need equality and I said we have
equality under the law here in America
we do but we're not required to have all
the same thoughts in our heads and so
he's saying wait until a hate crime is
committed like this guy like this as if
this guy this NHL player is is promoting
an anti-gay agenda they are just so
extreme and I am so sick of it and
everyone is sick of it I if the NHL
punishes this man in any way for not
participating in this ridiculous event
that they only do because it's pandering
to the masses they didn't give a [ __ ]
about this Corporate America didn't give
a [ __ ] about all these causes until they
until they got on and decided to go whoa
so to all the people out there who are
saying oh he should be doing this he
should be doing this wake up you were
being fooled by Corporate America they
do not really care about us they don't
care about your causes they don't care
about anything because if they did you
wouldn't have even had to ask so angry
so frustrating
this is about an attack on on religion
also and that's something that we've
been talking about a lot religion in
general and how it plays an incredibly
important life in so many in in so many
ways so this is not only anti-religion
it's anti-christian it's anti-islam
these people you know what it said in
the Quran that towards the day of
judgment that men will act like women
and women will act like men it's
interesting
um because we are coming on the end of
days I I don't know if it's this
Millennia or the next Millennia where is
going to be is the the final age in
Christianity also so maybe you know
there there's there's a lot of alignment
here and I guess maybe maybe it's
happening we're seeing it that'd be
crazy it'd be crazy yeah bring the
Rapture take up the good ones come on I
don't even care anymore so let the rest
just turn to [ __ ] this is ridiculous for
God's sake the manager is allowed to
have an opinion he's not hurting anybody
and I've had it had it had it had it
with these people trying to shut
everybody up because they have their own
thoughts you can not control the
thoughts in our heads and you're not
going to cut the [ __ ] because you have
awakened anger now we let you have it
for a while we let them have their
cancer culture and just all rolled our
eyes and go oh I can't believe this oh
and then everybody got good and quiet
they can't shut us all up but they can't
enough preach I [ __ ] had it I really
have I've had it we need Freedom we need
some freedoms that we have and these
people are trying to censor everybody's
censor us down to our thoughts in our
head are you out of your mind what are
you out of your mind get out of here we
got to go someplace all right you can
give the other show do me a solid follow
me on Twitter if you like this don't
forget to sub and like the video what
else Sunny follow sunny on Instagram
because he's cute and he's got a lot of
fun stuff on there all right thank you
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]